das ist eine breaking news denn der 36
jährige mann der erst seinen vater
umgebracht haben soll und dann in eine
gruppe radfahrer in mannheim raste und
dabei eine 71 jährige tötete er ist
gefasst wer was genau hat sich
abgespielt in mannheim kehrte am abend
in eine gruppe von vier fahrradfahrern
dabei stirbt eine frau die anderen
werden schwer verletzt und zuvor soll
der 36-jährige seine 69 jahre alten
vater getötet haben nach dem crash mit
den radfahrern flüchtete der verdächtige
und jetzt also die festnahme frage nach
bei daniela fahrt für uns vor ort in man
ein daniela wie und wo konnte der
verdächtige denn jetzt gefasst werden
genau wie gerade schon angesprochen
flüchtete der tatverdächtige zunächst
aus seinem stark beschädigten auto er
fürchtete zu fuß und während seiner
flucht sprang er dann auch in den rhein
und die polizei die wasserschutzpolizei
konnte ihn dann schließlich aus dem
reinen herausholen und festnehmen das
wissen wir bislang daniela über den
tatverdächtigen und auch über ein
mögliches motiv
laut unseren infos soll es sich bei dem
tatverdächtigen um stefan g handeln der
36 jährige soll bereits seit seiner
kindheit psychisch auffällig gewesen
sein er soll deswegen auch immer wieder
in der psychiatrie gewesen sein
stefan g soll bei seinen eltern in
ellerstadt in rheinland-pfalz gelebt
haben eben auch der tatort wo er oder
tatverdächtige sein vater umgebracht
haben soll laut unseren infos soll er
ihnen erschlagen haben das ganze ist
etwa 20 minuten hier von mannheim
entfernt und schon gestern sagte die
polizei dass sich der mann während
seiner taten in einem psychischen
ausnahmezustand befunden haben könnte
jetzt ist ja anschließend nachdem er
seinen vater tötete in diese gruppe an
radfahrern gerast wie möglich war das
eigentlich nur ein zufall dass sie sich
dort gerade gefunden haben dann weißt du
was über den zustand der
schwerverletzten
er also drei opfer liegen mit schweren
verletzungen in krankenhäusern die
polizei spricht wie gesagt von schweren
verletzungen nicht von
lebensgefährlichen das ist zumindest
stand jetzt stand der dinge der
tatverdächtige stefan g befindet sich
ebenfalls im krankenhaus mit einer
unterkühlung was man wohl darauf
zurückführen kann dass er eben in den
rhein gesprungen ist denn jeder part mit
den neuesten informationen zu dem fall
in mannheim vielen herzlichen dank